Patt 40 from Yahoo Sports has been all
over this and his most recent column
greedy parents soulless coaches the new
college admissions racket good morning
Pat good morning Dan how are you I'm
doing okay I'm wondering what bothered
you the most about this story other than
all of it you know clearly the parents
absolutely bothered me the most because
while you know it's I mean shameless
academic fraud and and and actually
screwing over their own teams by the
coaches I could understand if you are an
assistant coach or something at Yale or
I guess a soccer coach making I don't
know what you make it you know $70,000 a
year and somebody says here's 300 grand
or a million or whatever to get my kid
into school hey that would that would at
least be tempting but the parents I mean
here's the deal like first of all if you
have that much money does it really
matter where your kid goes to school or
is this just an all and ego thing so
that when you go to the country club you
can say yeah yeah my son will be
attending Yale in the fall you know that
that's true you know that that's true by
proxy I've said this that where your
kids go to school is a reflection on you
as a parent whether you know you believe
it or not you know people that people
will look at that no profile you and go
oh you know her her daughter got into
Yale son got into Duke as if that's a
reflection on her instead of maybe what
these kids did you know how hard they
work to get there no doubt about it
absolutely I've got three kids I had one
that went to Missouri one that went to
Georgia and my daughters at Stanford and
everybody wants to talk about the one
what's like they don't exist now how
much did that cost you $0.00 she's a
swimmer she's on scholarship there so
okay she actually did punch the golden
ticket all right and they did why by the
way I did not buy her her admission okay
all right all right did you write nice
things about Stanford sports basketball
game
stuff is the Stanford tree whoa
pad 40 compromised this situation at USC
in particular now there's other schools
involved in this but this is systemic
here you know when you you go up to the
third person in charge here the you know
on the pecking order you know Donna
heinel is a big deal there at USC and
then you've got some of these coaches
like how does this start how do the
coaches know I know you have sort of
this conduit this liaison to help you
here but I'm curious how many other
coaches around America were approached
to do the same thing it's a great
question wish I knew the answer but I
you know I would think there probably
have been several and I have heard
whisper since this broke of like oh well
you should see it this place in that
place if definitely what's going on you
know but these are the ones that got
caught but now USC you talk about
systemic as you said I mean there's a
reason people say USC students for
University of spoil children and this is
like the ultimate example of that but
you know they've had presidential
corruption they've had athletic
department corruption they bet you know
major NC double-a sanctions and now you
got this it's like my gosh what is going
on at that little Enclave in South Los
Angeles it's crazy that the mentality I
think that goes into the people that go
there and the people that work there
well there's arrogance that goes into
this or we're not gonna get caught
what's the big deal you know and I got a
kid into Yale and I got paid a couple
hundred thousand I mean I'm trying to
understand how you rationalize this you
have a water polo coach then maybe one
of the great coaches in that sport in
the history of the sport who jeopardized
everything you know a woman who was high
ranking in the sports athletic
department who jeopardized that you know
the soccer coach yeah like they all
jeopardize this because they probably
looked at their income what these kids
have who go into Yale and thought you
know what I get a few bucks here nobody
gets hurt and I get somebody into school
and nobody knows about it you think that
I had that's how that plays out I think
that's exactly
who am i hurting here and I'm already
not making enough money and I see all
these rich people I'm around them every
day I'm coaching them every day
where's mine and then you know the other
thing is though that you know those are
you know they they don't get that many
special admits those places and you're
taking those away from your team you
know you're saying I know you know I
could let it this kid who's actually
gonna help us on the team or I could let
in a fake water polo player and just say
that he is and I can get paid on the
side pad how does somebody not follow up
on a 5:5 basketball player who says he's
6 1 2 women who say they they road crew
but they weren't on the team you got a
kid who was I guess profiled as a punter
kicker like doesn't play helping or
somebody blow the lid off of this to say
by the way where is this kid that you
said that you needed in here like I
don't understand how it I mean it seems
I'm really stupid but oh it's very
stupid it's lazy it's a completely
sloppy oversight you know I don't know
there's the compliance Department or who
should be you know at least going out
and looking and saying okay here's all
your special bits can we see them you
know it's where are they or that
practice that workouts you know what are
they doing or at least like you know to
get a visual ID on all of them but when
they come in and I just think there's
lack of oversight there now we also know
compliance departments notoriously are
understaffed and underfunded so you may
be asking people who are low pay and not
enough of them to do too much work but I
mean I wonder that I mean I've looked at
like the the rowing teams and crew teams
in some place there's like 60 girls
listed on there
you really have 60 girls on the crew
team or what what's the deal I I I would
like to know some of the accounting
tricks to go on with these things also
if you're a quote-unquote recruited
athlete isn't it easier for you to get
in are the admission standards lower if
you're you're recruited athlete
no doubt about it yes that I wrote about
that as a matter of fact a little bit
yesterday my my oldest son who's a
really good student was rejected at
Stanford before he early in his senior
year you asked for early admission and
then I had a really good swimming season
his senior year and decided you want to
swim in college and we went to Notre
Dame northwestern Virginia Georgetown
were like hey you what do you think
they're like oh yeah absolutely
you know I'm not he may have still been
able to get in without swimming but they
were going to make sure he got in with
swimming and he wasn't a star but that's
the way it goes you get a an added boost
for those schools if you are going
recruited athlete Pat good to visit with
you never in a million years did I think
you know I'll talk to Pat 40 on
Wednesday free agency day and we're
gonna be talking about one of the
actresses from fuller house and one from
Desperate Housewives this is what aunt
Becky's done to us man that's
unbelievable damn damn that Aunt Becky
Thank You Pat thank you
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]